does the coronavirus know who's black
and who's white of course it doesn't but
when it gets hold of black Asian and
minority ethnic people in the UK there's
more chance they'll die from it it's a
stark observation and one which has
crippled so many families when Laraine
contracted coronavirus her chances of
survival were automatically decreased
her family are left hurting when she
left his house gone into a coma that was
that was the realization of how serious
it was and I was nervous that once she'd
left this house she wouldn't come back
and that's ultimately what happened I
couldn't even be there to hold my mom's
hand you know I mean and a son that
would surprise me for the rest of my
life after being instructed by the
government a month and a half ago public
health England released its review
looking at why people from a BMI
background are disproportionately
affected this work underlines that being
black or from a minority ethnic
background is a major risk factor and
the health Secretary's choice of
language was particularly poignant in
light of current global events black
lives matter and it has to those of the
poorest areas of our country which have
worse health outcomes and we need to
make sure that all of these
considerations are taken into account
and action is taken to level up the
health outcomes of people across this
country the review looked at health
records of at least a thousand people
and the impacts of deprivation age and
geography the findings found that in
black ethnic groups four hundred and
eighty six women and six hundred and
forty-nine men were diagnosed with Cova
19 per 100,000 population whereas in
white groups the number is significantly
lower two hundred and twenty women and
two hundred and twenty four men per
100,000 population people of Bangladeshi
ethnicity had almost twice the risk of
death and people of Chinese South Asian
and other black ethnicities had between
10 and 50 percent higher risk of death
when compared to white people our very
strongly suggests that the increased
risk for black and Asian people is not
attributable to a higher prevalence of
other medical problems or deprivation
among black and Asian groups so that
means that we have an outstanding
mystery if you like some organizations
fear this review may have come too late
it has no plan of action bet it doesn't
ask the question of how can we save
lives this virus has brought to the
forefront systemic issues that
governments have long since been aware
of social inequality and increased
deprivation within the PME community as
a result change may occur but it's taken
a pandemic and thousands of deaths to
reveal it in summon Rasheed's can use